[Music]
deep in our solar system a new era of
space exploration is unfolding beneath
the thick ice of Europa in the vapor
plumes on Enceladus and within the
methane lakes of Titan astrobiologists
are on the hunt for extraterrestrial
life we've honed in on these three moons
because each is an ocean world an
environment that contains a liquid ocean
and liquid can support the formation of
life
living organisms have to be able to grow
reproduce and feed themselves among
other things all of those functions
require the formation of complex
molecules from more basic components
liquids such as water allow chemical
compounds to remain in suspension
instead of sinking under the force of
gravity this enables them to interact
frequently in a three-dimensional space
and in the right conditions go through
chemical reactions that lead to the
formation of living matter that alone
isn't enough the small but complex
biomolecules that we're familiar with
are sensitive to temperature too hot or
cold and they won't mix liquid water has
an additional advantage in that it's
relatively temperature stable meaning it
can insulate molecules against large
shifts in heat on earth these and other
conditions in aquatic environments may
have supported the emergence of life
billions of years ago tantalizingly the
same could be true in other parts of our
solar system like these three icy moons
Europa which is a moon of Jupiter is
probably the most intriguing ocean world
beneath a surface layer of ice thicker
than Mount Everest there exists a liquid
ocean as much as 100 kilometers deep
astrobiologists think this hidden ocean
could Harbor life thanks to the Galileo
probe we can deduce that its potential
salt content is similar to that of some
lakes on earth
but most of its characteristics will be
a mystery until we can explore it
further like Jupiter Saturn also has
moons that might have the right
conditions for life for instance
Enceladus is a tiny ball of ice that's
small enough to nestle within the
surface area of the Gulf of Mexico
similarly to Europa it likely contains
an ocean deep under the ice
but Enceladus also has geysers that
frequently vent water vapour and tiny
ice grains into space astrobiologists
are curious about whether these geysers
are connected to the ocean below
they hope to send a probe to test
whether the geysers plumes of vapour
contain life enabling material from that
hidden sea although it's the best-known
substance for nurturing life water isn't
necessarily the only medium that can
support living things take Titan
Saturn's largest moon which has a thick
nitrogen atmosphere containing methane
and many other organic molecules its
clouds condense and rain onto Titan's
surface sustaining lakes and seas full
of liquid methane this compounds
particular chemistry means it's not as
supportive a medium as water but paired
with the high quantities of organic
material that also rained down from the
sky these bodies of liquid methane could
possibly support unfamiliar life forms
so what might indicate that life exists
on these or other worlds if it is out
there astrobiologists speculate that it
would be microscopic comparable to the
bacteria we have on earth this would
make it difficult to directly observe
from a great distance
so astrobiologists seek clues called bio
signatures those may be cells fossils or
mineral traces left behind by living
things and finding any bio signatures
will be challenging for many reasons one
of the biggest concerns is to make sure
we sterilize our probes extremely
thoroughly otherwise we could
accidentally contaminate ocean
worlds with Earth's own bacteria which
could destroy alien life Titan and Sela
dhis and Europa are just three of
possibly many ocean worlds that we could
explore we already know of several other
candidates in our solar system including
Jupiter's moons Callisto and Ganymede
Neptune's Triton and even Pluto if
there's this much potential for life to
exist in our own tiny solar system
what unimaginative esta the universe
contain so what are the odds of us
actually finding a habitable world
beyond our solar system check out this
video to learn more
[Music]